so welcome to the the stoah i am peter
lindbergh the stuart of the store and
this is a place for us to cohere and
dialogue about what matters most at the
knife's edge of this moment and today we
have Greg Sadler and Greg is going to
deliver a talk on staying inside on
solitude and cultivating interior life
Greg's a practical philosopher he's the
editor of the stoicism today blog he's
really cool guy I like him it's a good
energy about him and then the last talk
was quite fun and so how it's gonna work
he's gonna share his ideas and then
we're gonna I'm gonna warm up with some
questions and there weren't have Q&A
just write down your questions in the
chat box and then I meet yourself to ask
that being said I will allow great to
unmute himself and hand over to you all
right well thanks for inviting me back
in very much enjoyed our last session as
well and so yeah the the topic is
staying inside which we're all supposed
to be doing at this point in time some
people have more trouble with that than
than others and we'll talk a little bit
about that in in part of the
presentation and so what I'm going to
talk about is drawing on a number of
different thinkers who all I'll mention
and give references to anybody who wants
to contact me later for you know
follow-ups about well you know you
talked about Rilke we're looking real
good for that feel free to do that and
so what I'm going to run through most of
which is just me throwing ideas out
there at you but the last two which will
be a little bit more interactive are the
following first I want to talk about
this notion of interior life and what it
means and you know why we would turn to
philosophy to understand it and then
we'll talk about why why it's good for
us to cultivate interior life when it
sounds like yet one more thing that we
were supposed to be doing and then we'll
talk about the the crisis that we're in
and the opportunities that were given
and some of the challenges as well
then I also want to explore something
that's really connected with this this
notion of Solitude so you see that in
the title well what is that well we'll
go into that and I'll be bringing in
some stoic thinkers and some
existentialist thinkers to talk about
that another closely related topic is
something that we start to work on if we
look at ourselves and we find that we're
not entirely happy with it which is this
goal of integrating the self and Anna
ties in well with you know what Peter
was referencing in spiritual practices a
lot of those spiritual practices from
antiquity on are aimed at that an idea
then solitude and integrating the self
fit in with each other then I'll I'll
consider an issue that I think is almost
it automatically arises you know there's
worry about well if I'm retreating into
myself then aren't I
cutting off my relationships with others
and that's a valid concern but one that
turns out to be unnecessary before doing
it right and then we'll talk about some
obstacles to cultivating solitude and
and a rich interior life and that's
where we'll get a little bit more
interactive I've got a few that I want
to bring up but I'm sure that some of
you do as well and then I'll talk about
some recommendations that I have and I'm
not I'm not coming up with anything new
this is all just coming from these
authors who I'm referencing but we might
come up with some other good practices
for supporting and maintaining solitude
so interior life this is a kind of a
technical term in some you could call
them traditions of spiritual development
there's a lot of other synonyms for this
we can talk about the inner world of
one's own person interior already gets
used a lot
Stoics like to use this concept of the
inner citadel which comes from Marcus
Aurelius if you actually look at
epictetus he says watch out for inner
Citadel's because that's where not all
of them are great that's that's
sometimes what the vise is set up within
us with Rilke we have this space of
solitude or a zone kite that we're going
to talk about in the
and you know and it's made its way into
popular culture I remember in the
Sherlock Holmes show that that BBC put
out in the last five years or so he
talked about retreating to his interior
castle or inner castle or mind castles
how he framed it right and all of these
are really touching on the same idea all
of us have the beginnings of this just
by being human beings it's part of
normal human development if you didn't
have some sort of interior already
that's that's you on your own you you
really wouldn't be able to function well
and it's been a major topic of focus in
many of the ancient traditions of virtue
ethics so we could think about platonism
aristotelianism stoicism as being the
heavy hitters in that respect but it's
also something that the existentialist
gave a lot of attention to various other
you know wisdom traditions whether
philosophical or religious have have
spent a lot of time on discussing this
and some forms of psychotherapy as well
now some psychological perspectives
would rule this out if any of you
remember behaviorism which is kind of a
dead thing at this time you know there's
no interior tea at all well it turns out
that was that was quite false many many
other forms of psychotherapy and
psychology have you know viewed this as
something quite important so it's it's
it's a you could say it's a concept that
corresponds to an experience but it's
not a simple one it's something that's
complex and it's a little bit you know
funny that we can talk about in the
general because if we're talking about
it correctly there it exists in you and
you and you and me and it exists in a
sort of independent though similar way
in all of us so there's some interesting
problems that get raised by that which
we can talk about a little bit later on
but the point is we can we can
understand it and we can develop it and
we can use it because it is not just a
part of us
it is us this is us understanding
ourselves in the depth of our being
so why do we need to develop interior
life and not just interior life but
interior life of a certain kind I wanted
to begin with with Blaise Pascal's
dictum he says that and there's a little
bit over playing his hand here but but
it's quite true in many respects
humanities problems stem from human
beings inability to sit quietly in a
room along I think you've all heard that
before and it's quite true you know
people seek out distractions oftentimes
ego conflicts and they do so in ways
that sometimes are not particularly good
for them so why do we need solitude why
do we need an interior life it helps us
to develop a kind of independence and
self-sufficiency that that's needed in
order to be autonomous human beings and
be able to you know sit quietly in a
room alone or a waiting room or wherever
else we're supposed to be and it also
allows us to develop a responsiveness
and attentiveness that we otherwise
might be lacking and not just to what's
going on within ourselves but also
what's happening with with other people
to be able to take note of when somebody
else is struggling and and say the the
thing that could be helpful at that
point in time or to be able to share in
the joys or sorrows of another and so
you know it sounds kind of paradoxical
in that you know you're withdrawing from
things but you're withdrawing so that
you can come back to them we also I
think need this and you know that again
this will sound a little
counterintuitive we're all stuck at home
so you can take a break whenever you
want to right you can sleep in if you'd
like to there are the essential people
have to go off to work but many of us
are doing work from home or were just
staying at home well you can wear
yourself out even even on a vacation and
so what we're talking about as is
solitude here is needed for sort of
recharging
and reconnecting to deeper and more
important things getting away from the
superficial aspects of life and into the
deeper aspects of life and this leads us
to be able to engage in self-discovery
in a variety of different ways and not
the sort of navel-gazing narcissistic
self-discovery that they would then
announce itself on social media to
everybody hey look what I found in my
solitude or something like that but so
you know being able to honestly assess
who we are and get to know ourselves
better and that includes a lot of things
that we might not be entirely happy with
I'll talk about that in a bit but this
is necessary
Rilke is probably the person who has
identified this the best it's necessary
in order to generate a kind of depth
within ourselves and then the lack of
that depth is part of why Pascal is
right about about many people or even
about those who are developing it but
aren't using it at the right time and so
if we if we're cultivating this it can
lead to better relationships with with
others and the world as a whole or to
two other things we might think about
nature we might think about you know
animals or all sorts of other things
that were in relation to and now we're
presented with some some very
interesting opportunities and challenges
in the present one of these of course is
staying inside you know because of the
pandemic those of us who are actually
following stay at home orders
understandably there there are some of
our states here in America where the
governor's haven't actually declared
stay at home workers unfortunately but
you know the ones that that are on track
have told us all to stay inside and when
we're outside were isolated from each
other we're engaging in social
distancing we're supposed to be wearing
masks which already hide a good portion
of our our face that we would use to to
understand what's going on with other
people from each other yeah I remember
when I first started walking our dog
with
she was kind of upset about it she
didn't she didn't like the fact that she
couldn't see what was going on on the
but in my eyes and I think there's a lot
of that with people so there's there's a
lot of isolation going on and some
people look at this with a kind of
hostility you know who are you to
interrupt my activities and tell me I
can't be next to people and do whatever
I want to do there's other you know
we're seeing some interesting protests
going on right now a lot of which I
think are driven by ideological you know
it ideological judgments on their parts
some people are very driven by fear for
their own self but I think this is
offers us an opportunity to look at the
things that we're supposed to be doing
in terms of justice towards other people
we don't want to get other people sick
and a kind of decency and that's that's
one topic and we could explore that more
but then what do we do where even if we
have the right sort of mindset were
stuck in these constrained spaces unless
you're a celebrity I don't know if any
of you saw the celebrity video with all
of them in their palatial homes singing
imagine they had got a lot of backlash
from that because people are like man
I'm stuck in my studio apartment look at
these people so if you're if you're not
a celebrity and you're stuck in
something but smaller you might you
might have a sense of being stir-crazy
or isolated and we're also stuck with
other people you know interesting some
some other the people have been like
talking about being stuck with their ex
in the same apartment so that you know
you don't have a choice about who you're
spending time with and you know even
your pets might might get out of your
nerves from time to time you know
there's this funny thing that I think
some of you may have seen where you know
that all the dogs are saying you know
quarantine should go on forever and the
cats are saying everyone needs to get
back to the work my experience has not
been that with my cat who has been very
attention seeking sometimes to the point
where she'll interrupt video work things
like that
so you know we've got all these things
going on but you know we also have the
opportunity at this point in time to to
develop something that maybe some of us
have done but we haven't done to the
degree that would like and that would
include myself and we have this
opportunity to learn from from ancient
and medieval and modern thinkers about
the resources for developing a rich
interior life so I want to talk about
this conception of solitude in German
it's Anna's own kite that's the word
that that Rilke and Nietzsche use and in
Greek it's Emeril's that's the word that
Epictetus uses that's the word by the
way that we get hermit from a hermit is
somebody who goes off into maybe the
desert or the wasteland
to be alone and so so it has to do with
this being alone and there's good and
bad valence --is to these ideas it can
also be translated as loneliness and
even in real Capri Elka has two
different poems that are that are
referencing items up one of them is
about these two lovers that can't get
along with each other and have laying in
bed with back-to-back with each other
and they are totally alone even though
they're in the same room with each other
and the way it's translated in the lobe
I think it is the old father translation
of epictetus is forlorn this which is a
nice English term and epictetus devote
some some attention to it so you know
what makes this bad for other people
what are we experiencing that that's
negative right now part of it could be
disconnection from others and that's
when we want connections with others and
we can't happen so you know for example
I communicate with my children who live
two states away by phone and text and
you know that that sort of thing it
would be nice to be in the same room
with them at the same time I haven't
seen them since Christmas time and who
knows how long the quarantines right but
you know we're still able to maintain
some connection I think there's a lot of
people who just are disconnected
entirely from those who they would want
be connected with another thing that
Epictetus picks out he says what is it
that people don't like about being on
their own that makes them feel that it's
a negative experience and he talks about
the perception that you're without
resources that you don't have what you
need to to deal with things to cope with
things and I think that's that's a
common thing about you know worries of
that well what if something happens to
me who's going to take care of me and
then another thing that that could be
the case for those who are in you know
quarantine with others but are still
experiencing the negative side of things
on kite or solitude would be not being
able to be understood by others being
sort of cut off from not being
recognized or acknowledged in the way
that say you know Hagel talks about in
the phenomenology or that's that's
really the central thing driving that at
work by the way is drive for recognition
from other people for being acknowledged
and those are the negative sides of it
there are some very positive sides to
solitude as well and epictetus talks
about this in in a chapter in his
discourses and he's kind of
representative of an ancient view on
solitude it's important to be able to be
on one's own that is a goal for a fully
developed human being and he uses Zeus
being and of course we don't we don't
believe all this but some of the Stoics
believe there was a world conflagration
at the end of this universe though the
whole place had burned off and all
that's left is Zeus and epictetus as
well I mean azouz sad and lonely and
whining by himself when that happens no
he's he's a okay why because he can
stand to be by himself because he's
friends with himself he has a friend who
believe relation with himself Aristotle
says without all the metaphysics a very
similar thing in his discussions of
friendship can a person be friends with
themselves and that's that's that's an
important insight there Marcus Aurelius
of course has this metaphor
or citadel that i think many of us like
the most important thing about the inner
citadel thing is thinking about what do
you actually do in there what's in that
inner citadel is it just a place to you
know withdraw and retreat and keep the
world at bay which is what the metaphor
would seem to imply or are you
cultivating something inside of there
you know I guess it would depend on how
big your castle walls are you know what
you're able to put in there
Christian thinkers particularly monastic
writers like John Cassian view the the
you know withdraw to oneself as a place
where you can really see yourself as
what you are apart from the social self
that you share with everybody else and
encounter the divine and carry out a
process of healing or transformation you
see this by the way in st. Anselm's
proce loggia which is essentially a
prayer rather than a work of you know
strict argumentation on the
existentialist they grasp that it's
important to be able to build meaning on
your own that is not being given to you
by just cultural constructs or processes
and so you see Nietzsche talking about
the need for solitude it's less folks
are through straw but notice it's it's
not just a solitude of withdrawing
entirely by oneself
it's a solitude that you can share with
another solitary for nature and Rilke
would say something quite similar with
with Rainer Maria Rilke I would say this
concept of solitude particularly in
letters to a young poet but also in some
of his other works is developed to the
greatest degree and he talks about at
the very first this you know letter to
this young man he says withdrawn to
yourself and enter into the space of
solitude where you can identify what
your real desires are and see whether
you need to write whether you need to be
a poet if not do something else and if
you can't think of topics to write enter
into your solitude and think about your
childhood now I was telling him you
think about his childhood because the
man is a young man we can say think
about your other memories you know I'm
nearly 50 so I could think about you
know what was going on with
one of our dogs that we've lost and the
memories of him from just a few years
ago but enter into yourself
Andrea propriate those and you'll you'll
always have material to work on and and
we'll go suggest this not just for the
you know the purpose of creativity but
to get to know who you are and so one of
the other key ideas with this is this
notion of integration of oneself
integration of who you are what do we
find when we go in inside this is one
reason a lot of people don't want to go
inside we find that we're a mess I mean
you know virtue ethics is not about
telling us the perfect blueprint for how
we ought to be and then we just snap to
it and you know impose that upon
ourselves what we find out whether we're
taking a university lien path or a stoic
path or an existentialist path or some
sort of monastic Christian path is that
we are a battleground of different ideas
and desires and assumptions and they war
with each other
Epictetus actually uses this this term
that gets translated as contradiction
it's really mocking it means conflict it
means fighting and this the you know the
goal is to become less like that
and why you know because it makes us
happier to be like that and so when
we're talking about integrating ourself
we have this experience over and over
again of only partial integration and on
conflicts we might even realize that
we're in some respects bad people and
then we're posed with the question well
do I just simply embrace that and say I
am a bad person forever or deny it and
repress it and project it out onto
others or do we say wow I've got stuff
to work on I better like pay more
attention to this entering into solitude
being by oneself offers possibilities
for doing this provided one uses
resources that are available rather than
trying to reinvent the wheel and we
might also think about what are we
actually aiming at when we're talking
about integrating the self are we
looking at this higher kies
selves that you know we've got you know
think about plato's try parts on
tripartite so if you've got reason
dictating everything down to everybody
else and they have been followed mine
that's not even like a good read of
plato by the way but that is a common
portrayal of it or is it rather than we
want to allow the different parts of
ourselves to communicate with each other
to make their cases to each other and to
have their legitimate places but also
limitations placed on each other
this is what what Rilke suggests we
would be able to and this is what
epictetus suggests we would be able to
do through so engaging in a bit of
analysis and that you know presupposes
that we make the space for that analysis
ideally for Rilke if any of you haven't
read the letters to a young poet what
you see him talking about is the
discovery of a self and the the the
development of his self who isn't just
by itself but within that space finds
sort of organic connections with with
nature with God with plants and animals
other people places experiences and even
metaphysical things here the things he
calls the big things like fate and death
and so you know he actually we can talk
about a metaphysics of solitude in he
says we all belong to one vast solitude
sort of like when we go down we find
some common roots or bedrock that we all
share with it now I noticed I'm taking
up quite a bit of time go through this a
little bit quicker one main concern I
think a lot of people would have in
hearing this is ok well this sounds
really great I go into myself and I
cultivate this space of solitude and
okay I've got these thinkers that can
help me out with that but isn't that
going to isolate me more from other
people in my life and the answer would
be well if you're doing it wrong yes if
you're I mean let's say you're being a
jerk to everybody so they won't bother
you and you know they can't intrude into
your private time or something like that
it punished them for that that's gonna
screw things up but ideally
becoming solitary in this way
self-sufficient spontaneous more able to
know who you are should allow you to
have more genuine relationships with
others which is dependent on them of
course you know if you can't have a
really great genuine relationship with
somebody who is a terrible person but
you know I think in a lot of cases we
often get in our own way in our
relationships with people who aren't
terrible persons and we can have good
relationships with them and Rilke again
has a really wonderful way of framing
this in I believe it's letter 7 he when
he's talking about love and how it fits
in with solitude and the need for
developing ourselves before we commit
ourselves to others you know in loving
relationships he says that that love is
at its highest two solitudes that
protect and border and greet each other
so the idea would be that love is not a
fusion where you lose yourself in the
other person or anything like that it's
two people who can actually be on their
own but choose to be with each other
somebody else who talks about this by
the way similar way Liz Marcus Tullius
Cicero in his on friendship he talks
about his friendship or loving
relationships are these based on just
needing something from the other are
finding our missing part or something
like that and he says there are a lot of
people who don't need anything from
somebody else is his example of this is
Scipio africanus and they overflow they
give to others in friendship because
they see that as a good thing and so I
think building ourselves developing
ourselves within this space of Solitude
can very well equip us for doing the
things you need to do for others
particularly in this crisis you know
many of us have others who are dependent
on us psychologic
financially in other ways in the case of
my students for getting their grades in
on time and getting guidance and so by
by being able to build ourselves up and
understand ourselves better and pare
away at the parts of ourselves that we
want to to fix and improve in this space
of Solitude we can actually be more
available and accessible to others so
obstacles here's where I think we could
take you know a bit of back and forth
discussion I think one of the biggest
obstacles is distraction and I think
social media can be a big part of that
people are spending a lot more time
online and getting in fights on Twitter
I know this just looking at my own
Twitter stream I've done a lot of muting
of people myself so that I don't have to
like watch the endless bickering the
other things we might think about people
who are spending an awful lot of time
gaming or consuming streaming content
there's nothing inherently bad about
those things as a matter of fact you
there might be ways to connect with
other people but they can also be ways
in which we lose ourselves and we try to
you know consume the time that we could
otherwise be spending on on this another
thing that I think and I've seen this
coming from social media is this this
demand that's coming from some people
that we all be super productive I think
some of you have seen the memes where
people are saying things like if you
haven't learned a language or started a
business or done this or that during
quarantine you lack self-discipline and
you know basically the point is you're
looser right and these are very
counterproductive as a matter of fact it
doesn't even have to go to those sort of
toxic memes I have students who say you
know I'm seeing other students posting
in the discussion forums and I just
don't feel like doing it and I feel like
like I'm a failure for not doing it I
you know I did a video to tell my
students whatever good you do that's
that's something you know don't don't
downplay it don't measure yourself
against others I think that that's sort
of an enemy to the
solitude that we're talking about where
you you take if not necessarily just
yourself as the measure you take you
know classic spiritual directors or
thinkers or things like that as a
potential measure I know for me another
big obstacle is not being able to go out
in nature very easily I get to go
outside three times a day to walk our
dog and we do have a little park across
the street but I live in downtown
Milwaukee and we have a lot of green
space here in Milwaukee because of our
socialist mayor's past but I can't at
this point in time go and enjoy it huh I
I would you know normally be spending
quite a lot of time outside and I think
this may be the case for many of you as
well so then we have to focus on the
things that we can do you know maybe I
spend more time hanging out with my cat
who is a part of nature noticing just
how many fuzzy she is in comparison to
the dog you know or we can talk about
other things I can i we have a nice
window fortunately so I can I can open
it and get a breeze I can watch the
birds fly or home and another obstacle I
think would be other people in our
households particularly if they're
especially you know attention-seeking of
their meeting maybe that might make it
difficult to cultivate solitude so what
if Peters amenable to this what are some
of the obstacles that you're facing
besides those going to open it up to the
room for that yeah and then I'll talk
about some suggestions and then other
people can get suggestions too sure yeah
and I feel like this group has
discernment so feel free to unmute
yourself and then you can say
I'm Greg how does this play out if
you're an introvert versus an extrovert
during these times why don't I take that
sort of question afterwards okay in the
Q&A I'm looking for any sort of other
obstacles that people are having one
obstacle could possibly be broken up
sleep times I'm trying I'm you running a
set of procedures kind of like the stop
what am i doing right now
there are three possible things I could
be doing right now studying philosophy I
could be exercising or I could be
meditating those are like the three
things right the meditation is the one
that's the weakest so as I'm watching
youtube videos of philosophy lectures it
turns into I don't know what that cliche
or trope cats playing piano x' right so
then watching that for a while as a
refreshment I suddenly realize hey wait
a minute I'm spending too much time on
this right so that's two things the the
breaking up of sleep I'm not sleeping as
regularly as I could that affects my
concentration so then now I have to
manage my concentration and make sure
that I'm doing something that is of
value to me
for me philosophy is of high value so I
try to put that high in the priorities
but there still are multiple
distractions so it's about concentration
and distraction for me yeah I mean the
sleep thing is definitely an issue I
know if I don't get I can operate on
like six or seven hours of sleep if I
get less than that I'm pretty much shot
for the next day but what I hear you
saying is the other obstacle would be
sore like picking between different
things which one you you you ought to be
doing and then having to prioritize
between them I wonder too if there isn't
it kind of when it comes to spiritual
practices I think all of you have heard
of FOMO fear of missing out is this
worried that well if I'm not if I'm
doing this I'm not able to do this at
the same time and I think that can also
be disabling so many of us it keeps us
from being able to give ourselves
entirely to the one thing that we are
doing any other any other challenges
people are facing another one oh good
yes I this is a very brief one I have a
friend on the East Coast who is infected
with the virus and he's Ahnold like a
lock down that is perhaps more extreme
than the rest of us we can move around
our homes we can open a window he's
really locked in one room he lives with
his daughter and but he's you know he's
quite old and he feels like he's in a
prison because he's infected he can't
even leave his room yeah that's that's a
very tough one and as a matter of fact
that reminds me I I teach classes online
for prisoners here in Wisconsin and I've
only seen a few of my students recently
and see that means being able to chat
with them electronically because they're
all in lockdown now and they can't you
know they came to recharge their their
tablets that they use for their classes
and so it's real it's real isolation
yeah I think that so to say to somebody
like that oh well you've got the
opportunity to cultivate solitude almost
seems like a slap in the face right so I
don't know that this this advice is is
particularly helpful for extreme cases
like that but let's talk about some
suggestions then so I can tell you the
things that I've found helpful for doing
this and I think many of you as I've
been talking about this you probably
recognize that you've done things you
know like that as well and that you're
engaged in
in cultivating this interior space so
you might say what's been helpful for
you for me obviously drawing on other
authors who have things to say about it
that's that's always helpful for me and
exploring you know for example what
Rilke has to say about solitude in his
letters to a young poet in his poems in
his novels and then in his other letters
to other people it places me in
communication with Rilke it helps me to
sort of figure out what's going a wine
and I find myself quite emotionally
involved when I when I when I read and
then when I teach Rilke because I teach
them routinely to my classes there's
there's a kind of a connection there and
there's probably people like that for
you as well I think you know maintaining
and this will mark is talking about this
a little bit - the need for
concentration this deliberate focus on
on what is really essential and meaning
you know at least for that space and
times for pushing other things to the
side trying to eliminate the
distractions that we have for myself as
well and maybe some of you are like this
if you're somebody who is often over
scheduled and has a lot of things on
their their to-do list every day then
when you find yourself with these these
moments where you're daydreaming or just
kind of thing following out a train of
thought or thinking about an experience
you could recognize that and instead of
like cutting a lot of trim you know it's
almost like let's not turn off the valve
you just let it flow because there
you're actually entering into this this
place of solitude the way that you know
these thinkers have conceived a bit that
may not be a challenge for many of you
maybe some of you have no problems doing
that myself I actually have to like make
a deliberate effort not to cut off that
space of solitude the other thing that I
think is important is making time for it
maybe you pick out a particular hour of
the day mark mentioned meditation that
can be a great way to do this as well
there's a lot of different modes and
ways of doing that
other people you know what one thing
that I don't do that I think a lot of
other people find it incredibly helpful
is journaling and the only reason I
don't do journaling is because my
writing is terrible and I find it to be
a lot of effort and I don't really have
that much much time for it but I know
that a lot of people find that
incredibly helpful for getting to know
who they are and bringing things to
light and many of these great thinkers
who were talking about Marcus Aurelius
right he's writing a journal to himself
I don't know if any have been reading
Peters own sort of replication of that
he's doing something similar to that in
his letters so that can be quite good it
looks like we have a question in the
chat about so this ties in with the
obstacles how about the surrounding
environment yeah we make the connection
that our houses are a place of rest not
of study or work it makes it hard to
study in our home so two different
things going on there yeah if we've if
we've got the mindset that our houses
are a refuge a place of rest maybe we
have to do a mindset shift to make them
a place of study or work and this is
probably one reason why it's been
difficult for many people to transition
to working from home for me I've been
working from home you know as a teacher
my entire time you do so much work at
home and then you go to wherever you're
teaching but there's also another really
good point to that like we have
construction going on around us
constantly because one thing that you
can still spend money on during this
kovat pandemic is construction work and
it's a good idea it keeps people
employed right the construction workers
tend to spend their money quite a bit so
and there's less people on the street so
I'm not backing it but it does create
for a good bit of noise and distraction
from from time to time and I think there
could be similar things going around
with other people as well you know like
what if there was that great meme you
know all you saw the Italians singing on
their balconies did any of you see the
meme
where somebody tried doing that in New
York and his neighbors like opened up
their windows and they're like shut the
hell up
you know not everybody likes that that
that sort of thing kind of kind of based
on cultural assumptions I'd say so
let's go back to the suggestions thing
what other suggestions to any of you
have for how to you know cultivate this
this interior space well one thing is
coming up Greg is what we were talking
about before with that people in is sort
of reconnecting with old friends yeah
and I mentioned how I'm sort of viewing
that as a spiritual practice
reconnecting with friends in high school
and university and you kind of there's
like a sense I get like you kind of know
which ones you need to connect with
because there's like this sense of
unfinished business there
yeah and I've connected with like three
or four people who haven't talked to in
years and we reconnected you know shared
our stories and it was beautiful so yeah
I think that like connecting with people
and being in right relationship with the
people you were called to be in right
relationship with it's quite an
opportunity right now yeah and again we
were talking about this a little bit
before we started and I was saying that
Peter should do some writing about this
because I think that actually is a
legitimate spiritual practice it's got
some sort of structured procedures to it
you might say there's some definite ends
there's probably ways to do it not to do
it so I think I think that's actually a
good suggestion Maria has do you want to
read what Maria answered do you want me
to do it Maria if you want to unmute
yourself and share your thought this is
quite a good one actually yeah marina
sorry marina sorry yeah yeah yeah I'll
unmute you
you're not I yes I'm not marina this is
my work account that's March yeah my
name is mark but okay I have been doing
this I don't know how successful it is
but on waking up in the morning instead
of
leaping out of bed and rushing to get
into the car in order to make it to work
on time I'm laying in bed and it's not
sleeping it's not dreaming I'm awake but
I can imagine and remember because I
have lots of time and what I've been
trying to do is remember key points in
my life there are times in my life when
my memories are very not quite vivid but
the fact that I can remember them now
tells me that they were vivid at the
time right I'm always concerned about
memory do I remember the original event
or do I remember the last time I
remembered it right we got a copy theory
perhaps in there that after what jumped
but regardless of that I'm looking at
past times that I can actually remember
in the first person and I'm wondering
why do I remember these I'm also trying
to link them sequentially after trying
to put them in a rough order remember
this is so vague I question how well I'm
doing this then I'm looking back at that
time and then trying to see why am i
what am I remembering why do I remember
this what's the importance of that was I
part of it it was you know was I too
hard on myself did I expect too much of
myself when you're younger you kind of
have an idea of maybe the goal of the
kind of person you'd want to be right
how does that happen
how far did I go along the road you know
that sort of thing so on one hand
there's the first person memory at that
time on the second hand there's the
first person memory of me now
remembering it and trying to order them
then there's an attempt to understand it
and put it in context right I won't go
into too long because if I went I could
this could hours and who wants to listen
to that right but you know like being 8
years old and expecting that I should
work and take care of myself was
somewhat unreasonable
ok yeah I think
that that's the sort of thing that Rilke
is is referencing what he's talking
about you know going back into your past
and he talks about is this like vast
treasure that that we have and then you
know you engage you sort of like you
connect up with the previous you who you
know is you but of course a very
different person than you are now
you know the one the one thing for me
it's like I'm constantly trying to
recontextualize because when I was a kid
I had no real understanding of the world
around me yeah Briggs providing a frame
of reference right so what I wind up
doing is I wind up going back to the
first-person experience as a kid and
then looking at like what little history
I know and try to get like a I won't use
cosmic view that sounds too grandiose or
something but like a multiple contextual
view of that would my my little
experience would be nested in that
whether I knew it or not yeah that's
that's finding I mean we often talk
about like trying to find meaning right
and a lot of our finding meaning is just
that putting things into a context where
we can we can think that well this is
probably not all BS right there's
there's something really true going on
here this is often a very difficult
thing to articulate but you know you see
a lot of authors talking about this
including psychoanalytic authors this
this by the way is exactly what Lacan E
and analysis is about it's not about
like trying to cure somebody or you know
make them a perfect person or anything
like that it's to figure out narratives
that actually make sense put things into
perspective allow us to be able to
exercise some agency where we need to
and to be okay with the past without
calling everything great that wasn't
wasn't great let me take let me look at
its cause response how about how about
doing as Jewish people do have a day
dedicated to solitude no electron
almost necessary and no work either
that's actually a really nice thing to
do
I've been trying to work towards that so
as my wife for about five years and
we're still not able to have a Sabbath
day that's but the goal is to try to
reach that this this summer you know the
no electronics unless necessary is
actually a great idea because it's so
easy to get sucked in to you know the
world of social media the world of
Google Amazon Facebook all these things
are designed to entice us to spend more
and more time we know this you know that
it's part of what they call an attention
economy they're trying to suck up as
much as possible we need to take back as
much as we can I do want to get to the
two Titas question though about
introverts you know as are things
different for them so Tito do you want
to unmute and REE asked the question no
okay well I I mean I think that we can
talk about differences between like
extroverts way at the extrovert end
where they need and crave that human
interaction and then like really you
know the most introverted of the
interpreters and everything in between
like my wife for example is an introvert
who likes to have you know doing public
speaking to the large groups also enjoys
you know one-on-one meetings but winds
up having to do a lot of the in between
meetings and a drain sir I a myself you
know when I teach a class I have that
that kind of like oh afterwards Ian do
you feel a little bit like you've run a
marathon or something because I put a
lot of what I do it's like almost like
actors who are performing on stage you
know I'm making Plato speak or something
like that but but I'm not an introvert I
actually you know I I seek out those
sorts of things and I notice there's
there's a difference there and how we
handle the
being inside my wife is quite frankly
perfectly happy with quarantine
it actually removes some obligations to
be engaged with people and face-to-face
settings that that she is happy about
you know and you know we have also
discovered that there are many meetings
that could be an email she's she's happy
with that with me I actually miss being
in the classroom with my students the
most in part because I and like you know
I like the kids that I have and I enjoy
engaging with them but it's not it's not
something that's really like it's not
trying to be crazy or anything I think
there are some people who are probably
really needing that kind of human
stimulation like they'd like to be going
to sports events and now you know we
can't be there all together and that's
really wearing on them and you know
there's a there's a legitimate place for
that sort of stuff in life Tania has a
comment here building on mark mark
sharing about waking up and thinking
about past experiences I find an
interesting connection between the going
to the liminal space is upon waking and
going to sleep remaining my unconscious
yeah I think that that's completely
right and and like you know I mentioned
daydreaming in the middle of the day
when you just let your mind wander I
think that's another way to access that
as well and sometimes it can be object
focused like you know you're looking
outside and watching the birds flying
around and you're not you're not
watching them because you're going to do
anything with that you're just sort of
like letting your mind pick up on
particular objects I think that's part
of what Rilke suggests viewing and
that's that's part of what Epictetus or
Aristotle would say is being able to be
by yourself and just enjoy yourself
you know Peter I know you wanted to you
had some things that you wanted to talk
about yeah this was a little bit of a
haphazard Homan session today with the
question and answer and we only have 7
minutes so maybe I'll close with a
question for you
sure and yeah maybe it's a statement on
maybe I can tease a question out of this
but what's coming up is Zach Stein was
at the stove a couple weeks ago and he
was talking about how this is an
opportunity to be in right relationship
with being at home it's similar what
what you're talking about and how sort
of I can these uh slates play
capitalistic stages how we almost
instrumentalized the home it's like yeah
the home like we used the home as a
place to like eat [ __ ] and sleep to go
to work to be productive and build these
kind of fragile castles right and now
we're forced at home and now this is an
opportunity to build a relationship with
it and what's coming up is this another
environmentalist or some some of them
calling rewilding like rewilding things
and it's almost like the term rehoming
like we gotta every home things so I
don't I don't know if I have a question
there but just anything came alive or
not when I said that I think it is it is
a big shift for it for a lot of people
and actually this ties in well with with
the question that can kind of deepen
this from ikeda Pathak major restriction
and solitude is domestic abuse child
abuse conditions out here in India get
worse when there's a pandemic and
redressal mechanism that aren't
essential services do I think the
celebration of solitude is a first-world
phenomenon I would say definitely not I
mean it's it's found in almost every
spiritual path or tradition going way
back into ancient times and this is a
major problem here in Milwaukee where we
live you know all these kids being home
we know that child abuse has has spiked
and same thing with domestic abuse we
have some of the poorest ZIP codes in
the United States in this city so you
know what I mean what I'm suggesting
here isn't something that's meant to
address that I mean when it comes to to
any sort of like personal development or
spiritual path there's a lot of
different components to it this
component is not
meant to try to address that that said
having had quite a few students who have
dealt with these sorts of issues and
having had a lot of family members
sometimes those those experiences which
are very negative and shouldn't happen
can also be part of what gets gets used
and transformed within with it that
solitude as well so yeah so we have
about four minutes so I think it's
prudent to close here do you have any
closing thoughts for anyone on the
subject or things you can direct them to
to read more about it well so there's a
few questions here about like well with
what medieval authors and and mark is
right the Desert Fathers who you know
would include say John Cassian and
Evagrius Ponte coast you know the whole
monastic tradition is is worth checking
out in part because they made developing
an interior life as part of the
structured life depending on what order
they were in honest Terry central to
what they were doing and and you know so
like I mentioned st. Anselm
I was at Benedict and his pro slow diem
is quite an interesting book for looking
at going going within there's a lot of
other medieval authors who spent time on
that and it became more and more of a
thing as we get into late the late
medieval period you know leading into
what we notice set the cutoff at that
the Renaissance but I mean you can also
think about like what Descartes is doing
is activity within solitude right this
this meditative process that he's doing
which is not just a purely abstract
thing and so there's there's like
countless authors over over the ages in
ancient times you know Epictetus has an
entire chapter in the discourses in book
three it's chapter 13 where he talks
about that Aristotle I mentioned we're
looking at nikka Makena
books 8 and 9 Marcus you know the inner
Citadel I don't remember the exact
reference point for that maybe damn can
can provide that but there's there's a
lot of discussions about this throughout
ancient virtue ethics and then have been
running through the dozens your father's
early monastic literature and all the
way down to the present and I would you
know I would say whoever helps you in
this use that it's it's not as if we
have to have a cannon of people that we
you know we have to all stick to or
something like that
cool cool and people can find you on
your youtube channel that's for you
update most these days you would say
well in terms of updates Twitter or my
Facebook page are probably the best
places to look but if they they're
interested in videos you have the
YouTube channel I'm putting out about a
video a day and I also the Sadler's
lectures podcast as well and let me put
in a plug tube for I have a friend here
in Milwaukee who's also the co-leader of
the the stoic fellowship and we have
been doing a radio show called wisdom
for life which we'll be hearing later on
today episode five will be airing at
four o'clock Central Time so fine like
eastern time cool is that is that with
Nick no my friend Dan Hays okay cool
yeah awesome well thank so much for
coming on then sure yeah second time at
the store
you